[Music]
foreign
so this is one of my favorite lectures
because we are taking a big step from
solving just unforced linear
differential equations systems of
differential equations which we have a
lot of intuition and Powerful techniques
for now
to start solving for systems with
forcing so things like control systems
so we know that the solution of this
system is something like exit time T
equals e to the a matrix
T times my initial condition X naught
okay so we know how to solve for these
unforced Dynamics for the solution at
any future time by taking the Matrix
exponential of a times Little T where
Little T is time and we can compute this
by looking at the eigenvalues and
eigenvectors of a so we you know this
should be old hat for us pretty easy
but now what happens when I add plus b u
where U is some kind of external forcing
or disturbance I think of you as being a
control input some knob that I can
change in time to manipulate or change
the behavior of my system maybe make it
conform to some nominal engineering
objective
how does the solution change when I have
this plus b u okay so that's what I'm
going to drive today and probably over
the next two or three lectures
and I'll just kind of give away the
answer that we're going to still have
this initial condition response but then
we're also going to have a term because
of this control input which is going to
be an integral from 0 to T
still e to the a t now e to the A
T minus some dummy variable Tau times my
control Matrix B
times U of Tau
d-tau and for those of you who have uh
feel pretty comfortable in calculus
you'll recognize that this is actually a
convolution integral of this e to the A
T minus Tau B kernel convolved with my
forcing U of Tau so I basically take my
initial condition response with the
response I get from an initial condition
this e to the a t and I can involve that
with my control input so it's kind of
like my control input is continually
giving me something that looks like my
initial condition response and I'm
taking the convolution of that in time
so I'm actually going to derive this
from scratch in a couple of lectures
maybe next lecture but for now I'm just
going to build your intuition for what
kinds of phenomena you get for these
forced systems and how we can start
isolating this response and this
response for really simple inputs U of T
and then we'll build up to this generic
arbitrary U of T convolution integral
here okay so that's all coming up
um before I start I think what I want to
do before I jump into kind of the Matrix
math algebra here what I want to do is
start with a really simple motivating
example just to kind of build your
intuition for this
um and that simple motivating example is
let's say I want to stabilize a
uninverted pendulum okay so I'm going to
let's see if I can draw this I hope I
can okay so we're going to try to work
with this inverted pendulum
where maybe our pendulum uh has some
length
and some mass at the end of the length
and we are going to be able to apply
some control torque so we're going to be
able to apply some control torque so U
of T is going to be a torque that we
apply at the bottom I'm saying torque a
lot 20 torque is one of those words
that's funny the more you say it
I'm going to keep saying torque because
I like it and what we're trying to do is
stabilize this thing in the upright
position so that so that it's stable and
we know that the system in the vertical
position is unstable the linearized
Dynamics will look like a saddle point
so it'll have one positive and one
negative eigenvalue and so if I didn't
have this control torque Tau then the
system for small perturbations would
fall you know into its stable down
position and what we're going to do is
we're going going to use this plus bu to
modify the Dynamics to look more like a
stable system even in this upright
position
okay
so our Dynamics are something like you
know Theta double dot are our full
dynamics of the full nonlinear pendulum
is something like Theta double dot
equals minus sine Theta that's unforced
that's kind of the unforced part and if
I add a torque a torque is a generalized
force that acts on angles so in f equals
m a I would just have Plus
torque torque directly affects Theta
double dot
and so I can write this as a matrix
system of equations just like we have
you know throughout this entire class I
can write this as a matrix system of
equations where maybe what I'll do first
is I will write down you know Theta dot
equals Omega and Omega dot equals minus
sine
theta plus Tau
and from this I can write down a matrix
system of equations
um
DDT
DDT of theta Omega equals
[Music]
Omega minus sine Theta
plus a vector 0
um Tau okay this is now where we've
written this as a system of two coupled
first order equations in Theta and Omega
and now what we want to do is we want to
linearize this about the up position
where theta equals pi and I probably
shouldn't have drawn Theta being
measured from the top here technically
actually Theta is measured
uh this is a little bit confusing here
this is not actually how I'm Computing
how I'm measuring Theta I'm actually
measuring Theta
from the down position so
this is Theta and we want Theta to be
linearized about theta equals pi
the Jacobian of this we know how to do
this so I take
um you know let's call this f of x then
the Jacobian dfdx is going to equal
partial of this with respect to X Theta
is zero partial of this with respect to
Omega is one partial of this with
respect to Theta is minus cosine Theta
minus cosine Theta
minus cosine
Theta
and partial of this with respect to
Omega is zero okay so this is my
Jacobian and at my vertical position at
my um
theta equals Pi position
this uh d f d x at theta equals Pi the
upright position is just going to equal
0 1 1 0. and this is the saddle with
Lambda equals plus or minus one so so we
know that at the up position it's
unstable
good so now I can write this equation
linearized about the vertical position
and I can see is there some Tau some
torque forcing some control I can design
to change those linear Dynamics
so now I have
um and maybe I'll just do this over here
so now I have something like
um
DDT
of theta Omega
my linearized Dynamics are going to look
like 0 1 1 0 times Theta Omega
plus 0 1 times my torque Tau so notice
that I've I've kind of taken this torque
Tau out and now I've written this as a
matrix that's what my B Matrix is so
like literally I can say you know this
whole thing is a
this whole thing is B
this is my state X and this is my state
x dot and little Tau here is my control
input U so we have literally just taken
a non-linear dynamical system we've
linearized it about a fixed point about
the up position that happens to be
unstable so I sure would like to control
this system maybe this is a SpaceX
rocket launching onto a pad or a blue
origin rocket launching or a falling
onto a pad and this inverted pendulum if
I don't have control it's going to
topple over and crash and I need to
control this thing to keep it in the
vertical position okay and so this is
how to take that system and write it in
this form so this is an extremely
generic form we're going to see all over
the place in control systems and now I
just want to convince you that yes in
fact
there is a good
Tau there is a good control strategy
towel a good torque Tau that would
change the System Dynamics and make it
look stable and so in particular
um
if
and I have a whole class on control
theory a whole boot camp on control
theory you can go check out the playlist
on YouTube if I don't link it right here
right now in this video please put in
the comments and I will add a link but
there will be there's a whole controlled
boot camp
um
that talks about how to design this Tau
to change the Dynamics of a I'm just
going to present you with a towel that
will change the Dynamics in a favorable
way so if Tau equals
minus 2 Theta minus 2 Omega
and so specifically I'm assuming you
know if
I can measure
Theta and Omega
then I can stabilize I'm claiming that
and so in a lot of these control systems
like I as a human inverted pendulum I'm
right now an inverted pendulum I have a
pretty good measurement of my vertical
position and my velocity because I have
accelerometers in my ear and I have my
vision
um presumably with enough
um you know chemical stimulus you could
make it so my measurements are not
reliable and I might fall over that has
in fact happened before but if you can
measure Theta and you can measure Omega
and you feed those back and use those
measurements to design a good torque Tau
then I claim that we can stabilize the
system
and so essentially what that would mean
is that this would literally equal
um
a matrix minus two minus two times my
state variable X Theta Omega okay so
this this can be written in Matrix form
like this
and so plus 0 1 Tau so this uh 0 1 this
B Matrix times U zero one tau is going
to equal a matrix 0 0 minus two minus
two
times Theta Omega okay you can convince
yourself that this is true and so now
work I didn't tell you tell you how to
design this or why this is true I just
you know I did some math you know in my
office a couple minutes ago and wrote
this down and if you choose this Tau and
plug it in here now that system will be
stable I'm going to show you that right
now
so if I use that particular control
input then DDT of theta Omega
equals and it's going to equal this a
matrix times my state plus this Matrix
this B K times my state this Matrix
times this Matrix which is here so it's
this Matrix plus this Matrix which is 0
1
minus 1 minus 2.
times Theta Omega this is my
um
this is my controlled
system
so if I measure Theta and Theta Dot and
I fed that back into Tau in this exact
way then this is my closed loop
controlled system and you can verify
that this has eigenvalues this has IGS
Lambda equals minus one and minus one so
you should you know fire up python or
Matlab or do this by hand and just
really quickly convince yourself that
this has eigenvalues minus one and minus
one and so this system is stable so
that's maybe the most important part is
that our controlled system is stable we
have stabilized our control system okay
so that's the kind of idea of why we
care about these systems so we care
about being able to write down our our
unforced Dynamics X naught equals ax but
oftentimes those unforced Dynamics might
be unstable or they might not have the
right properties I want maybe they are
stable but I don't have the
responsiveness I want in my system maybe
the eigenvalues aren't fast enough for
my liking so if I have a cruise
controller in a car I might want to use
control inputs U to tune the Dynamics to
be more like a race car you know maybe I
want to take my my Subaru and make it
look more like a Ferrari with feedback
control okay so there's things you can
do like that
and this example is basically just
showing you that I can take my my my
system and write it as x dot equals ax
and if I have a control input often I
can write that as plus bu and under some
circumstances if I design my U correctly
in this case I'm literally saying
um you know this is equivalent to U
equals some Matrix times x this is my U
equals some Matrix times x if I use U
equals a matrix times x
then x dot equals a X plus b u becomes a
X Plus
B times K times x and that equals a plus
b k
X and so with control with this forcing
input U I can make my system look
different this will have different
eigenvalues this has different Dynamics
by by using feedback this is called
feedback
feedback control
because I'm literally measuring my state
X and feeding it back to my controller U
to my to my input u i get new Dynamics
entirely new Dynamics and I can tune
these Dynamics to have different
eigenvalues just like we did here we
tuned the Dynamics of a plus b k to have
stable Dynamics to stabilize this
inverted pendulum and that's a
generically very very powerful technique
that you can use in in control systems
so hopefully I
now we have opened this up to a
massively bigger set of problems not
just unforced x dot equals ax but now
when you add plus bu there's a lot more
possibilities of getting those Dynamics
in the next lecture I'm going to give
you examples of how to start solving
this uh getting towards deriving this
generic form of the solution here but
again in the back of your mind you
should be thinking okay I want to use
this for things like control systems and
understanding maybe this is a
disturbance how does my system respond
when I have disturbances and controls
and things like that
um so we'll derive all of this and then
there will also be a lecture where I
show you how to actually do this in in
Python and in Matlab cool thank you
[Music]